the story in this book was deliberately
intended to give children nightmares
nothing scary actually happens in it but
right away you notice that something
about it seems off it's about an old
steam train named Charlie and his friend
engineer Bob who has a special secret
Charlie The Cho Chu was really really
alive its author barl Evans doesn't
really exist she's a pseudonym for the
book's true author stepen King the story
first appeared as a book within a book
as a creepy story found by a character
in The Dark Tower series years later as
part of a fan promotion it was turned
into a real book at San Diego ComicCon
2016 in the story Charlie is replaced by
a new fangled diesel locomotive but
everything turns out all right in the
end or does it the illustrations leave a
lot of questions are these children
really laughing or are they
screaming